This morning when the
police commissioner and I spoke on
our morning briefing with the other team,
we were clear that tomorrow is a day
that's going to draw a great deal
of attention to our city.
And we know
there are many questions around
the movement of the city.
And we want to make sure that we send
a very clear,
loud message, as the deputy mayor stated
in New York City, is always, always ready
We know that this is a city
where our
NYPD and other law enforcement entities
must be prepared in any given moment
for anything to happen in this city
to start.
I want to make it clear,
the commissioner has stated
over and over again
there has been no specific,
specific, credible threats to our city
at this time.
Then on New Yorkers should go on
with their regular activities.
That means going to work,
going to school,
we're going to do our
job as we always do.
If you
use the drive which
state and take public transportation,
it is easy to get around
on public transportation
because we expect some disruptions
in additional traffic.
There's a great deal
of additional traffic
that may come in the city
and there will be street
closes
near the courts and throughout the city.
While there may be some rabble rousers
thinking about coming
to our city tomorrow.
A message is clear and simple.
Control yourselves.
New York City is our home,
not a
playground for your misplaced anger.
We are the safest large city in America
because we respect
the rule of law in New York City.
And although we have no specific threats,
people like Marjorie Taylor Greene,
who is known to spread
misinformation and hate speech of
she stated she's coming to town
Why are you in town?
Be on your best behavior.
As always,
we would not allow violence
or vandalism of any kind.
And if one is caught participating
in any act of violence,
they will be arrested
and held accountable.
No matter who you are.
And I want to, again,
thank the police department,
the commissioner,
for their response
and for the necessary preparation
as we deal with this major
historical potential event
that would take place in the city.
This time, I'd like to introduce
the police commissioner
of the city of New York.
Thank you, Mr.
Mayor.
Afternoon, everyone.
Thank you for being here.
As always,
the NYPD is prepared to ensure
that everyone is able to have
their voices
heard peacefully
while exercising
their First Amendment rights.
We do this work in close collaboration
with our federal, state
and local partners
because keeping our city safe
is absolutely a collective effort.
As the mayor stated,
there are no
credible or specific threats
to New York City at this time.
New Yorkers
may see an increased police presence
in parts of the city
and should anticipate
intermittent road closures
over the next few days,
particularly in Manhattan.
To avoid delays,
I too, urge
everyone to use
mass transit when possible.
As I said,
our job is to facilitate and safeguard
the rights of people
to express themselves
and those going
about their daily activities.
But I will remind everyone that violence
and destruction
are not part of legitimate,
lawful expression,
and it will never be tolerated
in our city.
The people we serve know this,
just as they know
that the NYPD will be out there
today, tomorrow and every day
to make sure that they are safe.
Thank you, Mr. Mayor. Sure.
Sure.
Well, we'll
take some questions, questions travel
as more details read
or anything else before
So the permitting is happening
is actually done through city hall.
But I will say that anyone who protest
is expected to express themselves
peacefully and orderly
rest assured in the rest of the power is
being raised once
that incident
is still under investigation at this time
of the year. Mr.
Mayor, have you noticed any
order for here at the airport?
A lot of people on notice that are
coming here for this event.
Any criminal matter? Or nothing.
We value our relationship
with our partners
and we're in constant
communication with them.
So if they do see an influx of people
or something out of the ordinary,
they will contact us.
At this time,
we don't see that happening,
but we will have real time information if
that does occur.
Anyone have specific
questions for you to share with the mayor
about where these
communities certain
how many blocks around the corner
should be closed for any minute?
Would that information
shared with the public?
So they're going to be
rolling road closures.
I'm sure you can understand
based on the sensitivity of it,
it's going to be moving,
but we will make sure
we have enough officers
to facilitate transport
throughout the city.
There is one area close to Trump Tower
that will have a road that is closed
just to facilitate his transport.
But beyond that,
there will be rolling road closures
intimately through the city.
We're trying to have a minimal
amount of intrusion into city life.
I want to ask
what additional measures is
the NYPD is taking
to try
also other members of his office?
We take any threats
or concerns of our elected officials
and anyone in the city very seriously.
So we have provided
some assistance in that regard.
And we are investigating
any threats that may be made to the DEA
or any of his his staff that the times
we're going to bring him in the
York.
As you know, a
number of laws were passed
when we went into having sensitive zones
and restricted zones
It's actually an easy felony
to carry in some of those zones,
even if you have a license.
Some of those zones
include courthouses,
federal buildings
and First Amendment activity.
So we're not going to move those
I think responsible
gun ownership
requires that, you know what,
the laws are where you are protesting
and we expect everyone to adhere to ours.
Well, going back to police presence,
how many officers do you expect
to be on the streets
and also the Secret Service?
I mean,
how have they come in
and basically told you what to do or,
you know, how much control
they're having over security?
We work with the Secret Service
all the time. These are our partners.
I won't go into how many numbers
of police officers will be on the street,
but we will have enough
to facilitate our mobile units
if we need to respond to anything.
But this is a collaborative effort
with our partners in the Secret Service
and make sure our
personnel are able
to stand there to cancel the dinner.
So you're listening there to Keyshawn
for the New York City
Police Department
commissioner, along with New York Mayor
Eric Adams, giving a security briefing
about the arrangements
ahead of tomorrow's historic day here in
in the United States
and in New York,
where Donald Trump will be arraigned
and after his indictment
on criminal charges.
We heard some headlines.
Others say there's a sending a clear
and loud messages.
They're not going to tolerate
any sort of violence
or there's no specific or credible threat
that there will be
any sort of violence tomorrow.
And they also issued a warning of sorts
to Marjorie Taylor Greene,
who is the conservative
congresswoman who may be urging her
to be on her best behavior
while running at leading
a protest tomorrow in New York City.
Let's go right
to CNN's
chief law enforcement and intelligence
analyst John Miller,
as well as the CNN senior law enforcement
analyst, Chief Ramsey.
So, John,
the headline, no specific
credible threat to the city.
What's your reaction?
That's what we
were expecting to hear in that
They've been looking at everything
from social media posts
to bomb threats
that have been called in
the week before last.
And and the entire threat picture.
And none of it
rises to anything
where they can say
this is something
where we think
there's something behind it,
where it's actually going to occur.
That's the good news.
The important part from an intelligence
standpoint is
you have to understand
that you're not going to know
of every credible threat
or what lurks in the shadows.
So the bifurcated posture there is
they're watching the threat traffic,
but they're also prepared
for the unknown.
And I think that's
what the police commissioner
was talking about.
Which is
they're not only following the threats,
but they're investigating
even threats
that are posted in social media
to say
who's on the other end of that threat?
Do they need to be interviewed
were they serious about the threat?
Do they have the capability
to carry it out?
And so far,
they haven't seen anything
that crosses the line.
But again, they're prepared
and they're prepared and chief
to the mayor mentioned
Marjorie Taylor
Greene called on her
and others
to, quote, be on your best behavior.
What do you take away from
that stark warning
Well, what I take away is it
doesn't matter who you are.
If you break the law,
if you engage in any act of violence,
you will suffer the consequences. Period.
And we learned from January six,
obviously, that
these things can't turn bad.
But having said that,
it sounds like the NYPD is prepared.
I have no doubt that they are
in a position to be able to deal
with whatever may come up
both in terms of just the regular control
of what takes place on the various sites,
but also having mobile units
that can move from point A
to point B very rapidly.
You know, the mayor
and the commissioner
both mentioned something that I think
people lose sight of.
Often times,
because we get so focused
on the security itself.
But for the average New Yorker,
they're not interested in
what's going on.
They just want to get from point
A to point B,
they want to get to the bank,
they want to get to the grocery store.
So you have to balance things
and keep people informed
when you have street closures
and things of that nature
so that they can move freely
or as freely as they can around the city.
And that's a balancing act
in and of itself.
You try to get people
to take public transportation,
but that's not always you know,
what people choose to do.
So it's a balancing act.
So they've got a lot of moving parts
there dealing with
what's going on
in terms of the ex-president, him
surrendering to various sites
that need to be dealt with.
But there's also day to day business
that goes on in the city.
All your resources
cannot be in one place.
They're going to be handling
everything that takes place in
New York on that day.